do you know where true intellectuals sit
where can you find them there must be
some where true intellectuals spend
their day riding Xbox Live messages
everyone knows stays Einstein Will Smith
Nikola Tesla is it Nikola Tesla I don't
know but I bet people on Xbox Live would
know let's read some xbox live messages
so we can build our brains bigger brain
bigger pp let's go I plant my SMG and
your mum's fish from Sir Roger balls
very nice a classic insult how can you
possibly come back from that response
how many chromosomes do you have more
than you boo said stab Xbox yeah when it
gets red circle and my riot gamers oh
wait this is what they do you just
caught you just caused as Sarah said how
do you feel you're really still talking
to me I'm doing it now how should I do
it
hi this is Ronnies dad do you know
Ronnie nope I'm so sad I'm typing this
on the Xbox oh so sad to see an
intellectual go like that I thought
Ronnie he really never thought Ronnie
retro itachi you have Mike no it's been
three years you don't have to respond I
think it's only polite it's only the
right thing to do is to reply you know
you know someone's still waiting for one
of this I know I bet I have some people
watching this me like alright I'm
sitting on this message and in 25 years
I'm gonna reply to it and it's gonna be
the most epic me a bizarre you're a
freaking bit sorry for calling you at
the fair we all get our own rash
sometimes with our words when we get
angry understandable it happens too even
to Xbox people ABS our wants to be your
friend I want to be your friend what a
wholesome story
this surely warms my heart good job abs
are I hit you up randomly because I was
bored of watching twitch streams here by
the way old are you eight just send me
the virus link its gamer XO dot-com
thank you kind sir for not wasting my
time Xbox users they don't waste their
time with formalities they don't waste
their time with social courtesy they
just get to the point like a true
intellectual AIDS kills mah noob I'm
only 10 my mom just got me this game I'm
sorry sorry Oh see this is the thing you
forget about a lot of times when you're
in the internet most people are just
below with 10 and now we're getting
angry about I I'm sure that if the
internet you have to show your face and
you had to show your muscle games and
you had to show your age if those three
three things were in front of every
message we would all just be so much
happier oh and and forth dick size yeah
that's right everyone has to post their
dick you know it's not a bad idea thanks
for being the worst teammate I ever had
please delete the game and never play
again for the sake of everyone else and
if you're in the party with the other
dude convey this message to him as well
you useless reptile new useless reptile
this really brings me back to when I was
young and I used to used to play
competitive games and he would just tell
people they there were the worst
possible subhuman piece of trash in
existence it was fun I miss those days
like video games is it such a great
outlet for kids to just be the worst
they could possibly be in a safe space
you know it's wholesome I don't know why
I told him
Bill Gates is not your dad yeah he is no
my name is penis gate brah only true
intellectuals will understand are you
five from Shrek 5 feet deep in your mom
bro leave me alone
bro stop we've all been there it happens
to the best of us
top arab nokia ringtone starts playing
okay okay okay bye Dave okay I know for
a fact you can't read then why bother
writing him that's the big brain that's
big brain right there god I really feel
like the chromosomes are increasing and
my IQ is depleting the more I read it's
wonderful I hate the letter K because
when combined with oh it reminds me of
what I'm not damn that's some really
Eilish level respect it I respect it I
like to move it move it
I'll move a [ __ ] tank tread across
your head well done well any sort of
enthusiasm of having fun or playfulness
in a video game get that out of here get
it out of here
that is not prolonging a video game and
you know it you're having fun in a video
game cringe you know the moment like
these super competitive games like like
MOBAs Oh like League when they started a
censoring toxic language that's the
depletion of fun in video games there's
no point as soon as the term toxic gamer
came to be gaming was over for me it's
like taking the fat out of McDonald's
food what's the point what's that point
and I'm saying it as a good thing I
think it's good kids have these they
need an outlet otherwise they'll just go
to area 51 and yell pickle Rick or
something far worse trust me
the trade-off I understand the trade-off
is important I know your IP address okay
are you gonna hack me no not my owner
please oh god I have a cold
gamers can we get an F is FS in the chat
ex ex ex ex ex gta4 AR I say you soon
you're literate you're licked on the red
say you soon if I got a message like
this I'd be terrified I'd be hiding my
IP address over 500 proxies my god you
better wipe your computer clean right
there's instant because X X X X X GTA 4
X X is coming for you right soon I will
bomb your mouth I hope your cats get
dire ah I hope your cat gets diarrhea
the area you hacker get dyra DRR DRR DRR
the Aria what is that a song it sounds
like a nice makeover you're gonna get a
diarrhea today we're gonna give you a
dire rap
what cuz you're a hacker message to all
friends and recent players I'm not a
pile it was one time thing alright one
time thing I misheard him say he was six
and thought he said he was 16 the court
cleared me of all the charges just
wanted to clear that up
Thank You Jacqueline Moss this is it
Xbox gamer go to the bottom of things
they care like no one else notice the
fact that there's not a single
PlayStation message here and there's
been like one the ratio of intellect is
pretty it's pretty clear it's pretty
eye-opening I don't know how to say this
but do you want to be boyfriend and
girlfriend in the costs every time I
joined you were so nice to me
blushes dude Sabretooth King is part of
face client you gotta say yes today come
on the title of this is simp you know
it's just a five year old right he's the
leader of face class it's it it's the
leader of face clan okay all right we
have a Playstation one I think I don't
know or it's his xbox
I'm not some beta [ __ ] that plays on
console I can't recognize you're being
reported for using cheap code expect a
notice from e a I will ensure you will
be banned from playing this game yes the
cheat code is called my opponent being
shat
being called the cheaters like the best
compliment it's told to you as an insult
it's like when you kill Pete I remember
killing people in modern warfare 2
because you know when they're coming
it's so obvious so you can sort of line
up the shot and then they look at the
kill camera they're like I'm like no I
just know how to play the game in your
room that's it
you guys want to see something pathetic
people have been saying I'm not a gamer
lately just because I don't know the
colors of the trucks in Slenderman 900
hours and I was never even part of face
client s in the chat boys I swear I had
more I legit think I had like over a
year in World of Warcraft it's a shame I
don't have my I don't have my old
account
I'm neva 143 hours it's not that bad
Dragon Age so I was such a good game
torchlight was really good too well that
went off on a tangent Jesus damn bro
you're a small that's actually a good
insult that's a rare insult subreddit
right there damn bro
you're a small baby I did not mean to
team kill my mama Khaled for diner and
my controller trapped dragged off and
this and it please don't report because
I don't want to bang I don't want to ban
sad face come on guys he did not man it
is not mad
cut him so freakin slack dude if you
don't manse you don't mind it's that
simple gamers not joining your party
what you want
hacker you're gonna cry maybe she's your
pants piss and come maybe that's what I
thought go cry to mommy is this the
origin of the meme it cannot be the
sauce when will this 13 days ago I don't
believe that that's an old one hey look
it's a panda stop swearing you [ __ ]
dude my mom is in the room and you are
talking about shape this is good or bad
who knows we will maybe never know you
are the baddest player I have ever seen
you're the worst at spelling baddest and
also baddest is the past tense of VIN I
am NOT a bad player
you're the paid planner you're the paid
player
damn that's a sick combat dude come back
why didn't you revive me you easily
could have I want the Thunder gun X team
that's a gamer moment right there that's
a gamer if I ever saw one
he wanted the Thunder gun XD we should
bring back XD I feel like we can do it
if we all get on board we can make XD a
thing again remember and when it all the
sudden it was encouraged to write XD for
some reason everyone's like oh you're
right XD that's so cringe who ruined it
who ruin it for everyone it's a great
it's a great emoji that I miss in fact
misusing a lot of times it's the emotion
I have right right now it's like when I
watch pickle rake I want to EXCI so
[ __ ] hard stop swearing Felix you're
making it harder for yourself or side
sorry side commend us a message to all
the recent players do you have a cute
sister I'm single and I like to play
xbox games I'm looking for a girlfriend
she has to be hunt like Megan Fox and
she has to be nice to me because I cry a
lot
[Laughter]
fair fair help me find my soul mate
come on Megan Fox and nice I can't be
that many you're a little bit fat damn
the subtlety in that is what really hit
said if you just call someone fat it
doesn't really mean anything if you say
someone little bit fat you call someone
stupid it doesn't feel the same as
you're a little bit stupid makes it a
bit condescending this guy knows it
especially how he
ironically typed your instead of you are
well done well done has layers to it
heart and kiss emoji
that's hella gay how I don't know what
fen there you are no homo if you're a
boy
I am attack helicopter oh yeah that's
funny attack helicopters about as cringy
as XD at this point I work for Xbox your
account is not bad please send 24-hour
trial code to be unbanned
thank you the Xbox team thank you Xbox
team this reminds me when I play tibia
you can send messages in tibia like
mail is our online uh great MMORPG game
it's very old it's [ __ ] now don't play
now but it was glorious back in the day
especially for a sweet hail fellow sweet
you know what I'm talking about you can
send messages dude it was like the best
game ever to just troll people cuz you
could just be the most awful human in
old time there was these messages going
around where people were sending out
pretending to be a game master which
were pretty convincing the way they
phrased it and they basically directed
you to a link that looked like the
official website but it wasn't it was
fishing basically before fishing was
popular and my friend got one of them I
knew it was fake but for some reason me
being the worst person of all time I
told him no it's real I don't know why I
did that
what's wrong with me so he put and the
next day he lost all these items and he
was so mad at me and I didn't feel
guilty I just thought it was so dumb for
falling for it good times that really
takes me back I love the teabagging
games you can't do these things in games
anymore like just take everything you
workdays for there's no games like that
now everything's protected to be safe
all the time am I right or am I wrong
like these things made the game fun I
remember another thing we used to do was
uh you can show off your items in the
game like you can push put them on the
ground to trade them so if you want it
to be cheeky you can like put it down on
the ground like one second I think I've
said this before you can put that like
if you had like a really good armor or
something you could put down on the
ground and then just take it up really
quick and be like ha look at that look
at that you can't do that in World of
Warcraft you can't do that in other
games if you have an item you can't
generally you can't lose it but no not
in this game so what we would do is we'd
be like hey look at this and then would
would mate wait for someone else to do
it as well be like oh yeah well look at
this except we would be ready with like
50 bags of just trash I don't know how
many bags of trash we're just a ton of
trash so as soon as they do it we were
ready to just throw all that trash above
it so that they can't pick it up again
so they would have to like scooch
through be like oh god they have to dig
through all this trash to get their
armor back but eventually they will get
back to it
we would be ready push them out of the
way hmm take their shoes that was fun
good memories sorry I keep going off on
tangents it takes me back I used to be a
gamer you know not anymore
are you a girl yeah can I be your foot
licking slave sir
see this is what you get these days he
gets Simms Simms weren't a thing back in
my day this whole videos become a back
in my day a gamer win the face of freak
off SMD GG though I don't know what SMD
is but GG at the end good job bruh
it means suck my Lal all good though all
good l'm al hahaha don't remember our
game but i'm sure i was just salty GG's
bro hope you're doing what Gigi this is
the best loss I've ever seen yes good
sock poop what in the world does I mean
good sock poop
oh good sock poop that's respect that's
gamer respect
I appreciate that sorry after
assassinated you it looked like I was
tea bagging I was trying to not get hit
in the head wow what occurred do you do
you type these out with the remote or do
you have like the the keyboard expansion
cuz I can't imagine anyone going through
the effort to write this for such a
subtle thing killer whale 1 6 7 has a
reputation to protect he can't just
he can't just let anyone think he just
teabags less than right no no no sorry
for crashing the war THOG and going afk
I had to let my doggie outside again
mister cuddlebuns wouldn't just let
something like that happen unless there
was a reason for it so he had to type it
out well you think I'm trash but you
haven't seen how I truly play you need
to open your eyes you're so close you're
such a bigot you don't know how I truly
play my power is only 10% this game all
right it's a video that's unusual oh
yeah you tell them all for playing you
seem a place I'm a grown man
you sent me a message first year I lived
in smelly Birmingham if you want a
simple conference never has pathology
[Music]
image for your excuse me you won't kill
me cuz I'm a gangster stop yonder you
run away because you're scared god I
miss gaming now I understand now why I
used to be a gamer it was a moment like
they use you're like a six year old you
have the intellect of a walnut and you
can't be trusted with anything I
remember always being so shocked at
people liking my YouTube videos in the
beginning because I was just such an
intolerable in Poehler able person
online that I only experienced with
other people online I was like just
trolling so everyone just hated me
online I would always get in trouble as
soon as I got any respectable level in
any video game I would get way too cocky
and they would just bite me in the ass
so I would never get anywhere there's
like old forum posts I remember in tibia
and oil Warcraft where people were
literally just like watch out for this
guy remember he's a piece of [ __ ] and I
would didn't do anything wrong by the
way I can refute those things if I find
them so yeah I was really shocked that
people like my youtube channel thanks
for watching guys I appreciate it so
much like if you enjoyed this video
check out the G fuels if you wanna drink
energy drinks that is slightly better
for you and tastes glorious of course
cheers gamers and I see you guys
tomorrow remember to subscribe and hey
hey hey hey you know what big peepees do
they play PewDiePie pixel ings of course
pixal ins is a creature collecting game
I'm the primary shareholder over a
bazillion players have downloaded and
it's got a perfect score
it's safe to say it's the most popular
game of all time pretty pie pick slings
is awesome deal with it
build with it
[Music]